[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publics en invité tous les
lundis soir à 19h30 sur LCP Public Sénat
à la veille de la journée qui peut tout
changer cette fois on entre dans le dur
les syndicats veulent mettre la France à
l'arrêt et même peut-être à genoux
bloqué le pays et faire payer le
gouvernement du taux de grévise demain
dépendra sans doute la suite du
mouvement du mouvement ce sera donc un
mardi crucial cette réforme des
retraites vaut-elles de fracturer le
pays alt-elle toujours un sens si
gouvernement accède aux demandes de la
droite le texte sera-t-il voté quelques
questions qui vont vous être posées
pendant cette émission bonjour François
Patriat merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
ce qu'on appelle un grognard de la
macronie infidèle entre les fidèles
d'Emmanuel Macron président du groupe
Renaissance au Sénat où est examiné le
texte jusqu'à dimanche prochain dans un
instant Brigitte Boucher est un tra
reviendront sur la désastreuse
communication du gouvernement sur cette
réforme Loris boischaud du Figaro sur
les suites politiques que souhaitent
donner le gouvernement les questions
d'actualité vous seront posées par
Vincent en route tout à l'heure et puis
vous avez accepté de débattre avec le
député LFI Urgo benalissi bernalicis ce
sera tout à l'heure après 20h nous vous
en remercions une première question
François patriar elle est simple et ce
qui est manuel Macron va tenir bon sur
sa réforme
je le pense sincèrement je pense que
c'est très forme
elle a été faite au nom de d'abord de la
nécessité de maintenir la solidarité
intergénérationnelle et de préserver
notre système par répartition qui est un
des meilleurs du monde aujourd'hui et en
second lieu elle est nécessaire parce
que si on veut préserver cette mesure il
faut que demain elle soit à l'équilibre
et donc on dit souvent cette réforme
elle est à la fois
inutile et les ajuste je crois que
elle est normale elle est nécessaire
parce que
on pense bien que le fait de démographie
montre que notre système est à bout je
vous donne un seul chiffre qui n'est pas
souvent évoqué il y a aujourd'hui 17
millions de retraités en France en 2030
il y aura plus de 20 millions de
retraités est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec
un tiers des Français en retraite on
peut travailler moins de main non je ne
pense pas ça c'est une raison
démographique le gouvernement ne l'a pas
mis en avant il a parlé de justice
donc on y viendra tout à l'heure avec
Brigitte Etam mais vous je note que vous
ne reprenez pas textuellement les termes
initiaux du gouvernement vous dites
c'est d'abord pour des raisons
démographiques le Emmanuel Macron
dites-vous ne va pas caler vous dites je
le pense sincèrement vous en êtes sûr
dans votre fort intérieur titre
personnel j'en suis sûr bien entendu je
pense que c'est une forme qu'il a essayé
de mener d'abord de façon systémique
pourquoi parce que en mai 68 sans doute
le gouvernement voulait tenir pourquoi
est-ce que saturer son quinquennat comme
on le dit c'est n'arrivait pas à bout de
cette réforme le problème c'est pas de
savoir ça tu le GARDENA le problème de
ces savoirs et là on arrive aux mesures
de justice si demain la France peut
avoir dans 10 ans 150 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires 15 milliards par
an et si nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants peuvent avoir une
retraite de peau de chagrin pas sûr
est-ce que s'il devait céder ça tuait
politiquement son quinquennat
honnêtement je vous réponds à la
question je ne vois pas aujourd'hui ni
le gouvernement ni le chef de l'État
cédé un engagement
je pense qu'il ne pense qu'il essaiera
pas parce qu'on ne peut pas c'est
Olivier du soft le ministre qui porte
évidemment cette retraite au
gouvernement soutenait hier dans les
colonnes du Parisien que la réforme est
de gauche est-ce que ça n'est pas une
énième maladresse formulé par un membre
du gouvernement sur cette réforme de
dire que c'est une réforme de gauche
quand vous comptez quand vous avez
besoin que vous appuyez sur les voies de
droite pour la faire passer et bien
justement
quand les républicains au Sénat vous
disent ça sera la réforme des
républicains elle sera de droite et que
le gouvernement dit aujourd'hui non
c'est très forme elle a d'abord été
initié par le gouvernement il y a eu des
discussions qui ont été faites avec les
républicains et il y a dans cette mesure
des mesures qu'il n'y a jamais eu dans
la proposition qu'on fait la républicain
ou Sénat pendant 4 ans il proposait la
retraite à 65 en 64 ans sec sans mesure
à côté or dans cette loi il et on nous
le reproche jamais parfois il y a pour
plus de 6 milliards de mesure
d'accompagnement social qui vise les
carrières longues les carrières hachées
la pénibilité et l'emploi des seniors il
y a 7 milliards donc c'est 7 milliards
ce sont des mesures sociales qui sont
aujourd'hui fait de là pour corriger
pour partie les difficultés de retraite
contre les carrières insuffisants
proposé de décaler à 64 ans l'âge légal
de la retraite jamais comment peut-on
dire aujourd'hui comme le fait l'olivier
du socle que c'est une réforme de gauche
je vous l'ai dit de parler mesures
sociales qui l'accompagnent et parce
qu'en fait on voit bien que la réforme
Touraine et ses 43 nuités ça c'est la
durée
35 à la retraite à 64 ans des facto elle
y aboutit donc c'était bien déjà cette
réforme qui aboutit qu'on le veuille ou
non aujourd'hui la plupart des gens
prennent leur retraite à plus de 63 ans
avec leur réforme Touraine et quand on a
commencé avec 43 nuités à 22 ans on est
à 65 ans vous voyez ça vous dites
réforme et de gauche et de droite c'est
je dis que c'est une réforme équilibré
est nécessaire encore une question la
retraite des parlementaires vous êtes
sénateur il se trouve que les députés
n'ont pas les Bourbons ici où nous
sommes réformés leur système de retraite
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
les sénateurs qui ont un régime spécial
entre guillemets réforme eux aussi leur
système de retraite pour se rapprocher
du commun comme on dit de la du système
comme je vais pas faire de langue de
bois
c'est que être parlementaire ce n'est
pas un métier c'est pas un métier donc
dire qu'on va être comme les autres
métiers c'est pas un métier c'est un
métier très aléatoire qui peut durer
trois ans deux ans pour certains 50 10
ans 15 ans 20 ans ou 30 ans bien
première chose 2 c'est un régime ce
n'est pas un régime spécial c'est un
régime autonome 3 les parlementaires
prennent leur retraite en moyenne à 72
ans c'est déjà spécificité que ne
prennent pas la majorité des Français 3
inexorablement je pense que la réflexion
a déjà été menée par le président du
Sénat et je lui en donuts il y a une PPR
qui est déposée aujourd'hui par le
groupe
de résolution pardon déposée par le
groupe Écologie Les Verts qui sera
étudié et je pense que le président de
la dit déjà le bureau du Sénat va se
réunir pour réfléchir à ce que pourrait
être demain une évolution des retraites
des sénateurs
que ça n'est pas un régime spécial que
vous êtes équilibré mais vous êtes
favorable à ce qui est une réforme de la
à revenir à un régime commun vous dites
quoi c'est de la démagogie
parlementaire ça fait très longtemps je
vous dis pas quand on a fait ça dans
Wikipédia
j'étais plus la première fois en 1980 ça
fait pas du mal de temps à l'époque les
parlementaires ne payaient pas d'impôts
de tout rien sur aucune indemnité bon
dès que je suis arrivé on a mis les
impôts fallait et c'est bien normal
ensuite on a dit attention une fonction
pas plus de pas plus de demanda pour que
mandats ensuite on a dit attention si
vous êtes autre chose j'étais présente
région pas plus qu'une fois et demi et
demi le l'indemnité parlementaire on est
prête ensuite on a dit je suis devenu
ministre on supprime les fonds secrets
tout ça c'est très bien je les ai voté
j'ai souscrit et c'est normal
pensez-vous aujourd'hui que dans
l'opinion publique le pignon vis-à-vis
des hommes politiques a changé pas du
tout pas du tout je vous donne cocktail
il faudra le faire sans état d'âme et
sans et sans espoir que ça améliorer par
ailleurs l'image du parlementaires dont
beaucoup de Français disent qu'ils ont
tous pourris par ailleurs mais je
voudrais faire le monter la demande des
Français et celle-là il faudra le faire
bien entendu il faudra le faire bien sûr
faudra réformer le régime de retraite
des sénateurs
dans le cas de ce qu'est la caisse des
sénateurs aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
prennent leur retraite à 72 ans Mayenne
et en plus il y en a qui deviennent
sénateurs seulement 72 63 ans donc on
voit bien que c'est pas c'est pas un
régime spécial c'est pas quelqu'un c'est
pas un métier à 15 ans le système on a
bien compris
Brigitte boucherie
boucher tomtomi bonjour à toutes les
deux c'est vous hein bonsoir François
Patriat vous dites qu'Emmanuel Macron va
tenir bon mais on entend déjà la CGT
chimie qui se dit prête à mettre à
genoux l'économie française est-ce que
quand même ça vous fait peur
ça me choque l'expression vous faites
que des gens qui représentent des
salariés dans ce pays qui représente
l'économie qui représente des femmes et
des hommes qui travaillent qu'on puisse
mettre demain l'économie à l'économie à
genoux ça veut dire que ce serait les
Français qui en pâtiraient les premiers
qui auraient demain des pertes d'emploi
des pertes de pouvoir d'achat des pertes
de recettes des pertes d'allocations qui
viendraient demain comment aujourd'hui
un syndicat peut-il dire pour réussir
nous allons mettre l’économie française
à genoux et le gouvernement peut tenir à
des syndicats qui sont à ce niveau de
motivation qui ont des propos aussi
radicaux la légitimité de la loi elle
appartient pas au syndicats la partie au
parlementaire chose sont claire c'est
pas les syndicats qui votent la loi et
c'est pas les gens qui votent la loi
c'est les parlementaires qui le vote les
parlementaires ont été élus pour voter
des lois et pas seulement pour débattre
c'est pour ça que je souhaite qu'on vote
à l'assemblée au Sénat ce qui n'a pas
été fait à l'Assemblée nationale mais
j'ai dit aujourd'hui que il faut
entendre les syndicats il y a eu des
négociations vous savez je pense que ça
fait trois ou quatre ans qu'on parle de
la réforme des retraites on en a parlé
avec Monsieur de le voir il y a eu la
réforme systémique elle a été abandonnée
parce qu'elle ne permettait pas
d'arriver suffisamment tôt à l'équilibre
en éclaire bien maintenant il y a la
réforme paramétrique qui a voulu le
gouvernement et qui a fait des
concessions depuis quand je pense pas
que la réforme brute telle qu'elle était
envisagée au départ 65 ans brute comme
le proposait les sénateurs à l'époque
républicains il y a eu des avancées dans
le domaine des carrières longues des
carrières arrachées de la possibilité de
l'emploi des seniors donc je pense que
les syndicats ont été entendus je trouve
je note par ailleurs
pendant 3 mois et par Monsieur Olivier
du socle et par la première minute
ils ont dit c'est là que c'est ça que je
le reproche parce qu'ils ont tous stoppé
sur les avancées qu'on leur a proposé
mais leur ligne rouge c'est les 64 ans
donc l'article bien entendu et c'est
pour ça qu'on trouve nous dit trouve que
ça va non plus sur la pénibilité sur les
carrières des femmes sur les carrières
longues ça n'ira jamais assez loin il
n'empêche que c'est des avancées
et que personne n'a osé faire jamais et
quand la réforme Touraine que j'ai voté
moi il y avait pas ces mesures là à
l'époque il y avait déjà les 43 ans
un scénario à la 1995 avec des semaines
entières de blocage est-ce que c'est pas
ça qui nous attend moi j'ai le sentiment
de en vous entendant aujourd'hui
d'entendre tout ce qu'on me dit sur tous
les plateaux pendant le mois de décembre
attention on va mourir parce qu'il y
aura plus d'électricité il y aura des
coupures tous les jours c'est bien de
prédire tous les jours un signe nado
Canada catastrophe j'entends bien c'est
bien de le faire moi je suis plutôt né
je pense que demain il y aura beaucoup
de monde dans la rue oui il y aura
beaucoup de manifestants oui il y aura
beaucoup de désordres dans les
transports oui
il y aura beaucoup de grève beaucoup de
grève écoutez moi j'ai tout à l'heure le
chiffre attendez je vais vous donner un
chiffre
parce que j'ai vu un chiffre fou par les
syndicats j'ai eu le chiffre du
ministère demande dans l'enseignement
primaire taux de syndic a déclaré pour
demain 35%. c'est inférieur à la
dernière manie de février alors à l'AFP
60%
c'est ce que dit aujourd'hui on va on
verra moi je pense que demain il y aura
plus d'un million de personnes je pense
qu'il y a autant de personnes peut-être
un peu plus qu'à la plus grande manif
qui est mois de janvier j'entends bien
pour ça
mais est-ce que c'est de nature
aujourd'hui est-ce que le gouvernement
doit dire parce qu'il y a 2 millions de
personnes dans la rue je recule
le 9 alors après demain euh j'espère
d'abord que le que le texte que
l'article 7 sera voté au Sénat je pense
je pense une chose c'est que j'entends
bien la volonté de de dire au syndicat
on va mettre le chaos on va mettre la
France à genoux on va bloquer la France
d'abord on bloque jamais la France la
France il sera pas bloquer mais
l'article 7 ça stoppe les manifestations
non la France elle sera pas bloquée il y
aura toujours des gens qui iront
travailler il y aura toujours des gens
qui iront à l'école il y aura dure des
hôpitaux qui tourneront il y aura
toujours des terrasses des services qui
fonctionneront oui la France sera pas
elle sera malmenée il y aura des
perturbations j'entends bien mais la
France ne sera pas bloquée demain c'est
l'heure alors on nous promet les
syndicats et les parties de position
c'est de promettent la journée de
l'Apocalypse on va voir on verra bien
demain
on voit les yeux non vous croyez pas que
demain ce sera complètement bloqué alors
est-ce qu'il suffirait que la France
soit l'arrêt deux jours trois jours
quatre jours avec les syndicats
manifestent pour qu'on arrête de
réformer ce pays
de semaine 3 semaines comme 95 et pour
l'instant on verra moi je pense il y a
une chose que vous n'intégrez pas je
pense que les Français sans doute
majoritairement ils ne veulent pas de la
retraite mais ils sont lucide ils sont
pas résignés
1 est nécessaire et que deux elle sera
voté et le savent c'est pas des natures
encouragé un mouvement très durable un
mot sur le fait que Bruno Retailleau
dise qu'il faut bloquer les bloqueurs
est-ce que vous êtes de son
avisé etc ça c'est les formules c'est
des formules politiques qu'on aime bien
employer aujourd'hui je pense que ce moi
autant autant j'ai du respect des égards
et de l'écoute vers ceux qui manifestent
dans la rue dans des conditions et qui
font grève autant autant je vous assure
je suis opposé à ceux qui dans ce pays
veulent bloquer le pays veulent créer le
chaos veulent créer le chaos veulent
mettre la France à genoux je pense que
quand les Français entendent ça sera de
nature à les faire réfléchir mais donc
est-ce qu'il faut
des réquisitions par anticipation dans
les transports est-ce qu'il faut des
réquisitions dans les raffineries ce
qu'il faut aller hein
il y aura un TER sur 10 qui marchera
demain on l'a déjà vu plus il y a déjà
trois des quatre terminaux métiers en
France qui vont être arrêtés pour 7
jours est-ce qu'il faut
rédiger pour écouter dans ce cas-là dans
ce cas-là la loi permet au gouvernement
de réquisitionner effectivement pour
livrer il faut le faire on le fera voilà
je pense alors et oui alors il y a une
loi enfin le Sénat qui est adopté en
2020 une proposition de loi pour
autoriser les réquisitions de grévistes
aux heures de pointe dans les transports
pour les jours de grève mais cette loi
n'a jamais été inscrite alors du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'elle le soit rapidement
justement pour qui est un vrai service
minimum qui soit en vigueur on va pas
multiplier les difficultés au même
moment
il doit moi je pense que ça ça doit être
négocié avec avec le représentation
cycliste syndicat et autres qu'on peut
qu'on peut arriver à faire comprendre
aux Français c'est un texte que je dis
pas que j'appelle de mes vœux mais que
je pense sera nécessaire si
effectivement ces mouvements devaient
pas contre alors vous vous dites les
Français sont résignés il y a 65% des
Français qui soutiennent les une grève
reconductible est-ce que vous vous êtes
sûr que vraiment l'opinion ne va pas se
retourner à force que les à force de
blocages que les jours de grève se
multiplient est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que ça va se retourner contre le
gouvernement j'entends bien ce qu'on me
dit sur les sondages vous savez je méfie
des sondages au jour le jour ce matin je
disais sur notre plateau moi je me
souviens d'avoir été sur des sondages au
moment du covid où il y avait 55% des
Français qui disent ne vouloir jamais se
faire vacciner
alors là les analyses de jour ça va ça
va dépendre ça de l'opinion qu'on les
Français de la façon vont se dérouler
les journées qui viennent c'est sûr j'en
ai qui viennent donc il faut regarder
ce soir qui fait une émission ce soir ça
veut dire un elle souhaite que le texte
soit voté 2 qu'il soit voté parler de
Parlement si possible 149-3 et que 3 le
texte de loi soit voté une fine à
l'équilibre qui ne manque pas tel ou tel
million comme ça tu es évoqué ici ou là
voilà
un mot sur la jeunesse qui qui semble se
joindre au blocage ça vous ne craignez
pas qu'il y a une agrégation des colères
que cette jeunesse qui en mai 68 a pu
faire voler en éclat les lois voilà très
bien ça vous inquiète pas
écoutez moi si vous me demandez si j'en
permanence m'inquiet non non non
le blocage lancé par Louis Boyard par
exemple le blocus challenge par exemple
on sépare le voyage j'étais choqué par
le fait de dire qu'il invitait qu'il
tirait au sort quelqu'un qui viendrait
visiter
du blocage
c'est ouvert à tous les citoyens et
c'est gratuit alors je trouve que
Monsieur Boyard s'octroi là à privilège
qui n'existe pas c'est de très mauvais
goût c'est de très mauvais goût parce
que je trouve que d'inciter les gens au
cas où au désordre si les glisser un
veulent faire grève ils n'ont pas besoin
que Monsieur Boyard les appelle à faire
grève non pas besoin que Monsieur
Mélenchon dites mettez le chaos dans ce
pays donc vous y voyez la main Jean-Luc
Mélenchon derrière ça bien entendu
beaucoup la gauche sur les bancs du
Sénat depuis le début de l'examen de la
réforme des retraites est-ce que
l'obstruction du Sénat est vraiment plus
douce qu'à l'Assemblée François patriar
elle est la même mais par contre la
force si vous me demandez qu'est-ce qui
différencie le Sénat je crois et le
président a raison de vouloir me montrer
qu'il est une chambre à la fois
respectueuse de la démocratie ou le
débat est certes dur il est âpre mais il
est respectueux et il est digne alors
que nous avons assisté ici dans cette
maison un débat avec des anathèmes des
injures des insultes frapper le
règlement du brouhaha permanent
j'ai dit que sur la sur la forme le
débat ce dernier dans des conditions
maintenant l'objectif l'objectif des
oppositions au Sénat qui soit communiste
socialiste ou Europe Écologie Les Verts
c'est de vouloir faire en sorte au bout
que le texte soit pas voté et pour ce
faire il multiplie de près depuis la
première heure de débat on a 106 heures
je vous rappelle au Sénat on avait plus
de 60 heures ici 106 heures au Sénat il
multiplie les artifices de procédure etc
pour faire durer le débat j'ai assisté à
le premier jour au premier séance hein
sur l'article liminaire
52 amendements identiques déposés par 52
sénateurs différents qui le défendent et
ensuite explication de vote j'étais hier
j'ai passé tout mon week-end au Sénat
jour et nuit j'ai assisté hier à un
débat sur lequel sur un amendement on a
eu droit à 42 explications de vote
sur la forme ça n'est pas comme
l'Assemblée sur le fond le position est
aussi dur seulement au Sénat il y a 40
il y a 240 députés qui font la majorité
aux autres de textes et 92 qui s'y
oppose on a parlé de l'article 7 mais il
y a une mesure qui va arriver après
l'article 7 qui est signé par la droite
sénatoriale qui veut une fin accélérée
des régimes spéciaux pour que les
régimes spéciaux s'éteignent des 2040
c'est un abonnement de Bruno retailleuse
qui vous clinique se la mette encore
plus de l'huile sur le feu qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette mesure alors le
gouvernement est opposé moi j'ai
toujours été opposé je l'ai dit parce
que je pense que là il s'agit de la
parole donnée et du contrat signé entre
l'employeur et un salarié si vous
rentrez casier autre sorte avec des
conditions de rémunération qui sont pas
celles que vous souhaitez mais qui vous
permet qui vous ont permis à des
roulement de carrière il est normal que
l'engagement qui a été souscrit soit
tenu ça on l'avait défendu on l'a
défendu vous souvenez la pelouse des
grands-pères pour les gens de la SNCF on
le fera de cette façon je pense
aujourd'hui il s'agirait d'une rupture
de contrat maintenant je dis à Monsieur
retaillot
vous voulez laver plus blanc que blanc
parce que en fin de compte qui est-ce
qui s'attaque au régime spéciaux vous
m'avez demandé alors la caisse des
parlementaires aussi quel est le
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui a décidé de
mettre fin au régime spéciaux qui l'a
mis dans le cadre de la SNCF qui va le
mettre ici demain à la RATP chez les
clairs de notre terre à la Banque de
France qui va le mettre demain c'est ce
gouvernement donc ce gouvernement qui a
le courage lui de dire il faut mettre
fin au régime spéciaux qui pour des
raisons des autres étaient tout à fait
justifié à une époque qui le sont moins
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement s'y attaque
et il le fait alors on peut faire de la
surenchère tous les jours et dire on va
aller plus loin de moi je trouve que
c'est une façon de démarquer à droite ce
texte alors que nous pensons et je pense
moi comme Olivier du socle c'est un
texte de gauche je le dis franchement et
bien de le se marquer avec le temps que
j'ai pas mal de marque de droite
convergence
sur la fin de dire une spéciaux nous la
soutiendrons pas et le gouvernement ne
se viendra vous demandez un effort
important aux Français travailler deux
ans de plus qu'à 64 ans mais à l'arrivée
il n'y a pas d'équilibre de cette
réforme à l'horizon 2030 le ministre
Olivier Véran a dit ce matin que
l'objectif d'équilibre serait tenu ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
allez enlever des mesures sociales pour
parvenir à l'équilibre de la réforme en
je crois que Olivier Veyron a eu raison
parce qu'il avait été repris sur le fait
qu'il avait dit qu'on l'état actuel des
débats il pouvait manquer quelques
millions je voudrais vos milliards je
vous rappelle les chiffres mignons
il manque 300 millions mais je vous
rappelle les chiffres cette réforme
aujourd'hui apporte apporte en économie
17 milliards 300 millions auquel je
rajoute un milliard 300 millions qui
vient de la caisse d'accidents du
travail et une maladie professionnelle
un milliard trois plus 300 millions de
la CNRACL bien ça fait près de 20
milliards
près de 300 milliards
de 20 milliards c'est 20 milliard dedans
il est prévu aujourd'hui un peu plus de
6 milliards de redistribution à travers
les mesures sociales qui sont prévues ce
que je pense c'est qu'au bout du compte
quand on arrivera en commission
mixparitaire où tout se jouera il faudra
choisir entre les amendements parce que
un amendement ce matin voté par le
contre lequel j'ai voté qui est sur le
CDI senior qui coûte 800 millions alors
moi je veux bien que Monsieur Retailleau
dise nous voulons être rigoureux ce que
nous voulons c'est l'équilibre il faut
que l'équipe soit respecté son emploi et
dépose un amendement écoutez il y a déjà
un index senior qui n'existait pas avant
il y a des mesures qui sont prises de
rétor sont qui sont pris dedans il y
aura toujours pas assez de choses
sociales par exemple il faut l'enlever
la surcote voilà la surcote sur les
femmes je vais voterai votre époux donc
augmente
je pense que cet amendement là il sera
discuté infini en commission
mixparitaire c'est un amendement que
notre groupe le groupe Renaissance
soutiendra au Sénat parce que ce que
vous ne dites pas c'est qu'il y a une
hypothèse de 4,5% de taux de chômage et
c'est quasiment impossible de tenir
finalement cet équilibre financier
quatre et demi pour cent taux de chômeur
ça veut dire 13 milliards et demi à
l'arrivée de manque alors comment vous
allez est-ce que c'est pas un mensonge
supplémentaire finalement alors vous
apportez-le
vous nous dites
nous tout le monde me dit dans la
position le corps dit qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de la retraite qui a pas de
difficulté financière que ça ira bien
vous me dites attendez mais les
conditions ou le corps dit attention
s'il y a quatre et demi pour cent de
chômeurs il y aura 13 milliards et demi
de déficits donc c'est lui qui le dit ce
que je souhaite moi c'est
qu'effectivement vous savez je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure si on veut demain assurer
le régime des retraites si on veut
demain qu'il y ait qu'il y ait plus de
services de santé plus de services
publics de moyens tout il faut que la
France c'est pas sur les retraites je
pense faut que la France travaille
plus donc ce que je pense c'est que
cette ce chiffre que vous me donnez des
4000%, nous a incite encore plus à plus
de rigueur et encore plus à voter la loi
est-ce que vous admettez que le
gouvernement a commis des
erreurs quand même sur cette réforme par
exemple sur son slogan sur les 1200
euros qui a été très mal compris par les
Français on a eu l'impression que ça
allait être 1200 euros pour tout le
monde est-ce que vous l'admettez qu'il y
a eu des véritables
erreurs de communication du gouvernement
j'entends dire le gouvernement a perdu
la bataille de la communication
comment voulez-vous gagner la bataille
alors que l'opinion publique
syndicat d’autre c'est focalisé sur la
mesure 62 64 donc les syndicats
il y a eu sur les 1200 euros je suis
quand même non
là moi j'ai compris bien entendu le
premier jour où j'ai entendu la mesure
dans le texte de loi je parle pas avant
le texte de loi j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit
l'un de Première ministre la premier
jour elle a dit 1200 euros c'est pour
une carrière complète au SMIC alors les
gens qui me disent aujourd'hui attendez
mais j'ai 800 euros j'aurais 1200 euros
non madame vous n'avez pas une carrière
complète et au SMIC vous ne l'avez pas
donc aujourd'hui si vous avez 32 invités
vous n'aurez pas 1200 euros les gens les
gens qui ont attendu l'avaient bien
compris il y a pas d'erreur de
communication en la matière alors
maintenant
personnes qui vont toucher entre 20 30
40 70 100 euros supplémentaires par mois
70 euros par mois de retraites
supplémentaire ça fait quand même 800
euros par an c'est quand même pas si mal
que ça aujourd'hui c'est pas beaucoup
pour titre mais c'est mieux mais c'est
mieux non mais c'est mieux que ce qui
n'est jamais été fait 1200 euros cette
là il y a pas eu d'erreur de
communication je m'insulte au début
c'était une carrière oui
une carrière complète aussi
alors dernière question pour vous
Brigitte oui sur les sur les débats
est-ce que vous êtes sûr qu'on arrivera
à voter cette réforme dimanche soir au
Sénat je le souhaite moi je pense
d'abord je le souhaite et le président
le souhaite parce que le souhait le
président
du Sénat du Sénat le souhaite lors
l'occurrence nous allons tout faire pour
y arriver il souhaite que le Sénat
montre qu'il est capable de débattre
dans le sérieux et la sérénité et qu'il
est capable de trancher et de voter au
bout parce que le Sénat c'est pas la
maison n'est pas là pour c'est un peu le
cas ici
je pense que le rôle du Sénat c'est
d'abord des débattre mais ensuite de
voter parce que le débat il est là pour
éclairer une solution au bout des
libération le débat il a lieu attendez
parce que moi quand vous dites que là
nous on n'a pas intérêt à prolonger
inutilement par des par des répétitions
à débats qui qui n'a pas lu de prolonger
à chaque fois à chaque fois le débat il
est fait à la fois par le rapporteur qui
répond au nom de la majorité de la
commission et par le Gouvernement qui
répond très très bien à chaque fois à
ceux de l'opposition comment on y arrive
voilà j'espère que votre article 7 dans
les deux jours qui viennent j'espère
qu'on va après la discutera à partir de
demain j'espère et ensuite il faudra
arriver dimanche à ceux qu'on puisse
alors ça dépendra comment va comment va
se conduire si l'opposition
jusqu'au-boutiste maintient son nombre
d'amendements le multiplie
l'intervention de vote je pense qu'il y
a au Sénat peut-être des moyens pour RAC
sortir un peu le débat je ne sais pas si
je ne sais pas on me dit qu'il y a le un
vote pour un votre compte malgré tout ça
ça suffira pas de faire passer
donc le vote bloqué j'ai cru comprendre
aussi que dans le repas où j'ai
participé avec les présidents on va dire
comme ça mais il y avait pas dit signé
mais il y avait un accord pour qu'on
parle pas de l'article 7 avant la
journée de demain mais qu'ensuite chacun
faisait des efforts pour arriver à ce
que ce texte soit voté au bout ça c'est
je comprends je comprends bien
qu'aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce que vous pensez que la
gauche ne veut pas voter dimanche soir
parce qu'elle sait qu'elle va perdre
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça qu'elle va
perdre donc elle voudrait délégitimer la
loi et moi je souhaite que la majorité
au Sénat y compris la gauche se sont mis
d'accord ce sont pas mis d'accord on a
évoqué la possibilité de dire
contrairement à l'Assemblée nationale je
vous dis que c'était le qui était émis
au départ moi je pense maintenant je
doute que l'opposition souhaite pouvoir
voter au pot jusqu'au bout
vous doutez que dans la réunion que nous
avons eu
sur le fait que on puisse discuter
jusqu'au 7 jusqu'au jusque la
manifestation pour arriver à l'article 7
et qu'ensuite les débats se
dérouleraient plus sereinement c'était
une entente tacite j'ai le sentiment
aujourd'hui que l'opposition revient sur
cette proposition elle dit aujourd'hui
ok
entendu merci beaucoup Brigitte merci
beaucoup Thomas on rejoint tout de suite
avec un peu de retard mais il connaît la
musique bonjour Vincent roux merci
d'être avec nous en direct du Figaro
live on vous écoute pour une première
question d'actualité à François Patriat
une polémique François Patriat à
laquelle vous avez participé c'est ce
qui se passe en ce moment à Versailles
est-ce que vous en voulez à ceux qui
vous ont incité à écrire un amendement
pour prolonger le mandat de Catherine
pegard en justifiant du fait que elle
était en poste au moment où les Jeux
Olympiques ont été décidés
alors cette question le gouvernement
avait souhaité que sur les sites ou les
Jeux Olympiques se déroulent où les
travaux sont déjà bien engagés où il y a
des mesures très importantes à prendre
où il y a des financements assumés où il
y a des équipements réalisés les gens
qui sont en situation puissent leur
rester moi je je vois pas d'objections
je reçois bien je pense que c'est une
politique inutile et stérile aujourd'hui
j'ai déposé cet amendement parce que je
pensais que c'était la volonté du
gouvernement que les gens restent en
place et le déposer j'ai compris que le
Sénat
ne le voterait pas qu'il faisait
l'unanimité contre lui je l'ai retiré je
n'en tire ni aucune honte ni aucune
gloire
vous en voulez pas à ceux qui vous ont
incité à écrire cet amendement qui a été
quand même très décrié très moqué mais
pourquoi je en voudrais ça mais pourquoi
je le rendrai chacun il y a des chacun
dans l'assemblée arrive avec ses
convictions avec sa volonté c'était le
souhait du gouvernement je le soutiens
je soutiens le gouvernement donc je
déposé l'amendement c'était même le
souhait du président derrière ça il y a
le il y a quand même une critique qui
est le fait du prince dans la
prolongation du mandat de Catherine
pegard le président ne m'a jamais appelé
ne m'en a jamais parlé je peux vous
assurer les yeux dans les yeux on vous
pose la question est-ce que ça n'est pas
le fait du prince que de maintenir
Catherine pegard à la tête d'un institut
malgré le fait qu'elle a atteint la
limite d'âge sont prédécesseur il y
avait la limite d'âge il a été remplacé
mais je pourrais vous poser la question
pour beaucoup d'autres personnes dans
les services au-delà donc et ça a été le
fait du prince de beaucoup de présidents
par le passé j'ai pas le sentiment
aujourd'hui que le président force la
main pour les dominations aujourd'hui en
l'occurrence alors pourquoi
beaucoup de soutien je pars mais
toujours à la tête de cette institution
prestigieuse
vous avez compris
parce que le gouvernement souhaitait
qu'elle puisse y rester je l'ai fait qui
va le remplacer je n'en sais rien et je
n'ai pas d'idée sur lequel qu'il
personne pour le remplacer j'en ai eu
par le passé quelques idées là
aujourd'hui ce sera le fait du
gouvernement du chef de l'État merci
beaucoup Vincent à tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup Vincent majeure merci quand
même c'est une importance majeure parce
que certains y voit effectivement un
abus une pas un abus de pouvoir mais un
fait du prince qui ne respecte pas
certaines règles donc c'était important
de vous poser la question franchement et
maintenant la parole à Loris
en l'occurrence
par la loi de respecter les règles les
règles étaient respectées
pour que l'état de fait soit
effectivement entre dans la loi
bonjour bonsoir Loris Brochot du Figaro
pour les questions politiques je reviens
à la réforme des retraites pour espérer
faire adopter cette réforme vous avez
besoin de la droite à droite qui domine
le Sénat la droite donc vous avez aussi
besoin des voix cruciales à l'Assemblée
nationale pour compléter cette
majoritaire lative arriver à la
majoritaire absolue est-ce que ce sont
des partenaires fiables les républicains
en l'occurrence
vous savez nous nous cherchons les
compromis pour avoir une majorité sur
les textes de loi que propose le
gouvernement
nous l'avons vu par exemple sur
l'énergie renouvelable où nous l'avons
fait en compromis avec la gauche là ce
sont sévère les républicains
avec nous sur ce texte là il ne l'a pas
échappé au gouvernement que le souhait
des républicains à travers la campagne
de Madame Pécresse qui annonçait
fièrement qu'elle vote qu'elle était
pour la retraite à 65 ans le fait
réitérer que chaque année les
républicains dépose un amendement
similaire qui se rapproche de la
décision du projet de loi du
gouvernement qui lui apporte des mesures
sociales supplémentaires bien entendu à
partir du moment où il y a une majorité
possible ici quand vous avez une
majorité relative au Parlement il faut
bien trouver des alliés pour faire
passer le texte est-ce que ce sont des
partenaires fiables je vous pose la
question parce qu'on a vu que
différentes voix s'exprimées au sein du
groupe les républicains notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale autour d'Aurélien
Pradier est-ce que ce ne sont pas des
voix qui pourraient vous manquer le
moment venu lors d'un vote finale
éventuel je parle pas de l'Assemblée
nationale je n'y cherche pas je ne sais
pas comment aujourd'hui il fonctionne ce
que je vois c'est au Sénat au Sénat je
vois le Président rotaïo je vois le
président Marseille je vois monsieur
malhuren ou même et d'autres qui sommes
d'accord pour faire en sorte de sauver
ce système de retraite et de voter un
texte de loi qui soit à la fois juste
équilibré et qui permettent de conserver
le système ce que vous dites à ce
moment-là sont plus fiables qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale non je pense que
ils sont d'abord ils sont majoritaires
et ils sont majoritaires sur cette
position aujourd'hui donc je vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on irait on irait à
dire à l'encontre d'un accord possible
sur un texte que souhaite le
gouvernement enfin pour être masochiste
et dans la majorité alors on a vu que
des frondeurs c'était exprimés c'était
manifesté ces dernières semaines une
douzaine de frondeurs entre les groupes
Renaissance modem horizon je parle là de
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
pouvez faire le pari que lors d'un vote
final éventuel à l'Assemblée nationale
aucune voie ne manquera dans la majorité
j'ai fait ce pari je pense parce que
j'en parle souvent avec mes amis avec
mes collègues avec les responsables de
groupe
j'ai encore vu aujourd'hui je pense que
au bout du compte aucune voie ne
manquerait la majorité donc et je pense
que j'ai les républicains ni d'absence
je dis à une près peut-être je sais pas
peut-être une preuve
je pense que aucune voie de manquer en
tout cas pas 10 ni 12 ni quinze ni 20 là
la très grande majorité si ce n'est tout
ce que je crois voteront le texte
c'est-à-dire Renaissance horizon
même
d'horizon parce qu'on a vu que une
demi-douzaine de Philippe East renacle a
voté la réforme pour ceux qui n'ont pas
les j'entends bien les membres
d'horizons appartiennent à la majorité
le président leur président Édouard
Philippe lui-même a dit qu'il soutenait
le texte de réforme qu'il soutenait le
gouvernement il y a pendant le débat des
volontés d'amendement d'amélioration
parce que certains parlementaires sur la
pression de leur mandant souhaite faire
passer les amendements ça crée des
mouvements d'humeur mais au bout du
compte je pense pas qu'une voix manquera
y compris chez l'horizon et alors
comment passer à autre chose après la
réforme des retraites ce qu'il faut un
remaniement pour ouvrir un nouveau
chapitre par exemple est-ce qu'il faut
une dissolution
alors d'abord je pense que la réforme
des retraite c'est pas l'alpha et le
méga de toutes les réformes à faire le
président de la République à ce courage
de prendre d'engager des réformes
nécessaires que d'autres n'ont pas voulu
faire par le passé et de le faire sur
des sujets difficiles
c'est une étape très importante
politiquement donc c'est pour ça que
c'est important de savoir comment
rebondir
quand je vois le calendrier qui nous
attend derrière je me dis que la réforme
peut pas s'arrêter aux retraites alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire 15 jours
après nous séduisons du texte
il va y avoir un texte sur la justice il
va y avoir un texte sur la fin de vie il
va y avoir une réflexion sur la réforme
des institutions il va y avoir un texte
de travail moi j'ai regardé avec mes
amis du groupe j'aurais dû demain matin
les chantiers qui nous attendent demain
sont des réformes importantes cela ne
nécessite pas une un remaniement il me
semble que le gouvernement si le
gouvernement mène à bien cette réforme
l'amener dans l'ensemble je suis pas
même à juger de l'action de tel ou tel
ministre aujourd'hui je pense que le
remaniement n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
à titre personnel je pense qu'il n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire aujourd'hui quand elle a
dissolution en cas de
dissolution par exemple s'il y avait une
réforme du sac de retraite là ce serait
ce serait une situation chaos je pense
aujourd'hui difficile ce serait
difficile donc et comment prendre à
autre chose je n'imagine je n'imagine
pas ce scénario je pense je vous dis que
la réforme sera votée qu'elle sera voté
149-3 et qu'elle sera équilibrée donc
j'écarte les scénarios j'ai pas besoin
de me faire mal ou de me faire peur les
choses soient claires et donc la
dissolution c'est autre chose la
question que je me pose moi à titre
personnel à titre personnel c'est est-ce
que c'est assemblé dans sa composition
actuelle telle qu'elle est dans la
conduite qu'elle a aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'elle peut durer 5 ans à titre
personnel à titre personnel j'en doute
j'en doute je vois pas comment je ne
vois pas comment on pourrait voter 5
budgets avec 10 ou 15 49,3 alors
qu'on pourra voter des textes et on les
vote il y a pas un texte qui n'est pas
passé aujourd'hui depuis que depuis la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron et cette
nouvelle mand tous les textes sont
passés tant qu'on pourra voter les
textes il n'y a pas besoin de
dissolution
ou les oppositions sur la manifestement
en vue de vouloir renverser le
gouvernement ces jours-là il faudrait
dissoudre en cas d'échec sur la loi
immigration par exemple qui est l'un des
prochains chantiers ouverts par
l'exécutif les négociations n'ont pas
commencé avec les parlementaires on n'a
pas encore rencontré les ministres pour
en parler laissons le champ sera
difficile pour la faire adopter puisque
la gauche est contre la droite est
contre à ce stade
un mot sur les élections sénatoriales
vous êtes sénateur président du groupe
Renaissance au Sénat et c'est impérial
c'est dans 6 mois au mois de septembre
vous avez 24 élus dans votre dans votre
groupe Renaissance est-ce que vous
risquez de perdre des plumes lors de ce
scrutin puisqu'on sait que les
intervalles sont indexées sur les
élections locales municipales et que le
camp Macron n'est pas très fort dans les
villes ce que je pense c'est à dire
qu'on peut gagner des sièges on peut
organiser même si je sais que les
mouvements au Sénat se feront à la marge
sur quelques dizaines de parlementaires
je pense que les élections sénatoriales
sont le résultat des élections
municipales de 2020 qui vous l'avez noté
ne sont pas défavorables c'est un échec
pour le camp du président de la
République ne doit pas être favorable
bon tiens donc je ne vois pas demain
comment on pourrait effectivement avoir
tripler le groupe je ne dis pas ça
aujourd'hui ce que je dis c'est que
parmi les sénateurs certains je n'en
connais pas qui ont des mérités je pense
qu'ils peuvent aujourd'hui être en
situation d'être réélu
pratiquement tout je le dis tous même
c'est être élu et je dis que nous
pouvons gagner je vois déjà des
départements nous pouvons gagner
quelques sièges il y a des groupes qui
perdront des sièges il y a des groupes
qui nous aideront je pense que le groupe
Europe Écologie Les Verts peut gagner
des sièges parce qu'ils ont gagné des
grandes villes ils ont gagné des grandes
villes les Verts aujourd'hui donc les
grandes villes apportent des sénateurs
je pense que le groupe de Monsieur
malurel compli libre pourrait avoir des
transfuges qui viendraient chez les
républicains qui se plairaient plus cher
aussi je vois beaucoup d'autres groupes
qui vont perdre de quelques sièges mais
l'équilibre du Sénat ne sera pas changé
pour ce qui concerne le groupe que je
préside j'entends me battre avec eux
pour que les sortants aujourd'hui sont
en situation parce qu'ils ont fait un
ex-mence de travail au Sénat d'être
réélu demain merci beaucoup Loris à très
vite évidemment dans auditions publiques
une question avant de d'accueillir votre
confrère de l'Assemblée gouvernale ici
Emmanuel Macron nous dites-vous depuis
le début de l'émission va tenir sur les
retraites est-ce que il pourrait
envisager
peut-être dans un souci d'apaisement
et de concorde
et qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous serez favorable à ce qu'il
envisage finalement une taxe
exceptionnelle sur les super profits
je pense que la philosophie d'abord
latex elle se fait au niveau européen
donc je pense que une personne
pays moi je le souhaite pas je souhaite
qu'on l'a déjà obtenu par beaucoup en
doutait on a déjà obtenu des résultats
Bruno Le Maire a mener ses négociations
le président de la République l'a fait
au niveau européen je pense que si nous
devons taxer les super profits prendre
par exemple ce qui se fait déjà
aujourd'hui il faut le faire européen je
ne vois pas aujourd'hui je ne souhaite
pas une petite personne
par pays et puis aussi au niveau des
pays et il y a des pays comme ça
est-ce que vous pensez attendez que la
France n'est pas déjà le nirvana des
impôts nous sommes le deuxième
c'est un impôt c'est un impôt d'exoner
c'est dans la peau
je pense que le message que nous faire
passer un moment où les résultats
apparaissent en termes d'industrialis
dans ce pays où on a plus d'usine qui
sont construites où il y a 30 37 000
emplois dans l'industrie qui ont été
créés qui sont pas fait depuis 20 ans où
on est pour la quatrième fois le pays le
plus attractif aujourd'hui en Europe
pour les investissements étrangers je
pense que dans ce pays-là donner le
signal de taxe supplémentaire
aujourd'hui surtout que on l'a vu avec
total on sait comment ça fonctionne
puisque les profits que fait en France
total ne sont pas de nature
ce ne serait pas celui-là
Hugo bernalis-ci s'est installé en face
de vous bonsoir Monsieur le Député la
France insoumise évidemment deux thèmes
comme d'habitude on commence par les
retraites peut-être évidemment je pense
que c'est le sujet du moment moi je
voudrais savoir Monsieur patriam ce
sénateur comment vous assumez de porter
une réforme contre la majorité de
l'opinion des Français les sondages se
multiplient ce succèdent encore un
récemment publié dans l'humanité
aujourd'hui 65% des gens sont opposés
radicalement à cette réforme des
retraites et 65% sont d'ailleurs
favorables à une grève dure
reconductible pour mettre en échec cette
cette réforme est-ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression de faire une réforme contre
le peuple alors
moi je suis parlementaire et en tant que
parlementaire j'essaye depuis de
nombreuses années de faire en sorte de
ne pas voter en fonction j'allais dire
de démagogue de la démagogie momentanée
mais de l'intérêt général
de 65 % des gens sont opposés à votre
temps mais aujourd'hui ils sont opposés
mais ils étaient déjà opposés à 60 %
lorsqu'il y a eu la réforme Fillon
aujourd'hui qui est-ce qui me remet en
cause la réforme client personne à
chaque fois qu'on a avancé dans la
réforme des retraites non mais personne
veut dire aujourd'hui vous exagérez
la suite de la réforme c'est la suivante
c'est 65 % bon donc vous avez la réponse
à votre question personne ne remet en
cause les réformes qui ont été faites y
compris par Monsieur Hollande que j'ai
soutenu personne pas que c'était
nécessaire si elle n'avait pas été faite
on serait dans le danger qui nous menace
aujourd'hui on aurait alors là x
milliards de déficits mais attendez
pourquoi pourquoi
même pas besoin de réformer réformant
c'est ça votre votre
tautologie
ce qui était vrai il y a 40 ans quand la
réforme à 60 ans
il y avait pour nous il y avait pour
nous il y avait une démographie
favorable aujourd'hui non
non non non non non non pas du tout pas
du tout je vous pose la question
aujourd'hui il y a je vous à l'heure je
l'ai dit quand on va passer de 17
millions de retraités à plus de 20
millions de retraités c'est-à-dire un
tiers des Français à la retraite
pensez-vous que l'on puisse aujourd'hui
travailler moins dans ce pays oui vous
pensez vous le pensez vous allez
dépenses d'accord
politiquement je suis pour la retraite à
60 ans et je suis pour qu'on la finance
j'entends bien mais oui parce que c'est
une question de financement vous avez ni
plus ni moins vous venez
la financer par les taxes et des impôts
entre autres tout à fait aléatoire ce
que les profils aujourd'hui ne sont pas
forcément les procès de les profites
demain les impôts sur tel ou telle
activité qui déclin dégringolerai demain
mais très les retraites à bas moi ce que
je vous dis quand je vous dis que les
justes je vous dis un 20 millions de
retraités demain notre système ne nous
le permet plus et tous les pays autour
de nous l'ont compris deuxième chose si
vous pensez aujourd'hui qu'on peut
continuer à avoir 15 milliards de
déficits par an parce que c'est 15
milliards une année sur 10 ans c'est 150
milliards moi ce qui me paraît
aujourd'hui moi ce qui me paraît juste
aujourd'hui bonjour Aujourd'hui c'est de
ne pas laisser à mes enfants à mes
petits-enfants une France où ils
auraient une retraite de peau de chagrin
et où il y aurait 100 ou 200 ou 300 ou
500 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
c'est ça ma responsabilité c'est la
raison pour laquelle malgré le pignon
des Français aujourd'hui et bien je vais
voter ce texte alors pourquoi vous ne
votez pas des recettes supplémentaires
si vous ne voulez pas laisser des
retraites de peau de chagrin aux enfants
qui demain seront des adultes et des
futurs retraités parce que c'est votre
réforme qui va produire cela précisément
c'est-à-dire un allongement de la durée
de cotisation et le fait que les gens
partiront à la retraite avec s'ils
veulent partir au même âge
qu'aujourd'hui avec moins de retraite
mécaniquement ou sinon en moins bonne
santé parce que l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé elle ne s'améliore pas le
recul surtout vu l'état de l'hôpital
public donc je rejoins le débat sur la
question non non c'est le même débat la
question sur les supers profits on a
posé la question 15 milliards 15
milliards mais je voulais trouve tout de
suite d'accord c'est 56 milliards qui
ont été versés au CAC 40 en dividende
c'est 80 milliards d'évasion et de
fraude fiscales par an alors que vous
votre majorité non non c'est le même
sujet c'est de l'argent public qui
échappe sur échappent c'est de l'argent
qui devrait revenir dans les caisses de
l'État s'ils y étaient on se poserait
pas de question on sera en train de
discuter est-ce qu'on préfère 69
59 ans pardon ou 60 ans ou si on
pourrait descendre à 58 ou à 57 ans et
demi pour certaines professions voilà le
beau débat que nous pourrions avoir pour
le pays parce que peut-être que vous
avez une vision du retraité qui ne fait
rien qui ne sert à rien dans la société
qui est là en train de profiter moi
c'est pas la vision que j'ai du retraité
la personne qui est à la retraite
continue d'être utile pour son pays pour
de sa famille pour ses voisins et pour
tout le reste non non mais vous devez
répondre
ça ne va pas avoir le temps de répondre
moi j'essaie de vous répondre j'entends
bien votre discours sur l'état des super
profil et cetera j'entends bien là
aujourd'hui j'ai ce que je voudrais vous
dire
le régime des retraites c'est un régime
par répartition qui fait que les
retraites des retraités sont financés
par les actifs et pas par des impôts
quelque chose soit clair donc voilà
alors quand vous avez dans la fonction
publique aujourd'hui ben moi d'actifs
que de retraités l'État met 30 milliards
robots et donc l'État met 30 milliards
au bout mais tout ça tout ça c'est 30
milliards qu'on ne met pas à côté pour
faire du développement économique de la
recherche de l'immigrations
fait et qu'en baissant les charges que
les entreprises nous avons aujourd'hui
augmenter le dividendes vous le dites
jamais pas du tout ils ont des recettes
fiscales nettement supérieures à ce
qu'il y avait par le passé très net mais
vous le savez
rebonds du covid ça n'a rien à voir mais
pas du tout radicalement aujourd'hui
mais pas du tout c'est prouvé par A plus
des aujourd'hui comme il y a plus de
gens qui travaillent comme il y a plus
de richesse comme il y a plus de
bénéfices les gens payent plus d'impôts
plus de tactes plus de cotisations non
c'est pas vrai parce qu'ils sont mal
payés et que les petits salaires sont
exonérés de cotisations sociales par un
certain nombre de niches fiscales c'est
ça la réalité aujourd'hui du
fonctionnement économique c'est que les
basses salaires ne cotisent pas c'est
pour ça qu'il est urgent d'augmenter les
salaires mais pourquoi vous me parlez
pas du chômage mais je vais vous en
parler tout de suite il faut augmenter
les salaires augmenter les salaires
diminuer le temps de travail dans la
journée dans la semaine et dans la vie
augmenter les faut augmenter les
salaires et travailler moins très bien
exactement exactement
vous défendez ce qui est capable c'est
votre projet politique parce que vous
pensez le ruissellement magique comme ça
vous êtes de gauche ah contrairement à
vous oui vous êtes de gauche très bien
bon moi je vous permets pas de me juger
je continue
pas à me juger moi je peux dire que je
n'ai pas de gauche qui est de droite
écoute-moi bien je vous dis que je suis
déçu social que vous devez vous dire
expliquez-moi alors pourquoi si vous
êtes de gauche un pays voisin qui
s'appelle l'Espagne dans lequel le
gouvernement et socialiste et le
ministre communiste les affaires
sociales communistes vient de faire
passer en Espagne la retraite à 66 ans
et 3 mois son de gauche hein comme vous
et voilà et eux ils disent bah on est
raisonnable on veut assurer les
retraites on veut assurer l'équilibre on
veut assurer l'effort intergénérationnel
et on le fait expliquez-moi comment ces
gens de gauche et après on passera un
autre sujet mais je vois que ça vous
intéresse l'Espagne mais je crois qu'ils
sont en progrès par rapport à la
situation intérieure eux ils vont dans
la bonne direction
contrairement à vous vous voulez aller
plus loin vous voulez à 6 après demain
c'est très bien c'est votre projet
politique ça vous revenez à 43e vite
c'est mort les doigts de ne pas être
dans un état social comme la France ou
les syndicats on on luttait dur on
conquis le fait qu'il est cotisations
sociales que les gens se payent leur
retraite d'accord c'est pas un cadeau de
retraite c'est la génération suivante
qui paye la retraite les gens se payent
leur retraite oui les gens globalement
se payent leur retraite les actes
aujourd'hui il est retraités
d'aujourd'hui aussi oui oui très bien
c'est comment fonctionne
exosquelette en rien d'autre et que
c'est ça votre projet de société
d'interpréter ce que j'ai dit par
ailleurs
vous avez l'attaque le sarcasme la
critique facile
je vous donne un Master 2 en la matière
c'est gentil maintenant
franchement ça n'est pas agréable on
passe pas par la pas par ce genre de de
en vous aviez encore un sujet le débat
est animé tant mieux mais pas de mise en
cause personnelle vous aviez un autre
sujet qui vous tient à cœur parce que
vous êtes un spécialiste à la commission
des lois exactement c'est la question de
la police judiciaire et de la réforme de
la police dans son intégralité par sa
départementalisation vous savez que deux
de vos collègues Nadine beluro et Jérôme
Durin viennent de rendre leur rapport
ils sont nos homologues on a fait la
même mission ici à l'Assemblée nationale
avec Marie guevenou et il plaide tout
comme moi pour un moratoire sur cette
réforme en disant ce n'est pas le moment
de réformer la police nationale en tout
cas tel que indiqué par Gérald Darmanin
nous avons des grandes échéances coupe
du monde de rugby Jeux Olympiques en
2024 ce n'est pas le moment déstabiliser
l'institution judiciaire il y a eu
encore aujourd'hui ce matin des
rassemblements devant tous les services
de la PJ du pays où les agents de la
police judiciaire dont les meilleurs
enquêteurs du pays
de la réforme c'est de départementaliser
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un chef unique de
la police dans chaque département du
pays regroupant ceux qui font police aux
frontières ceux qui font police ceux qui
font sécurité publique ceux qui font
renseignement territorial tout ça un
seul et unique chef là aujourd'hui où
nous avons des directions différentes
des emprises territoriales différentes
et des budgets qui sont qui sont
différents ma question c'est est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à ce qu'il y ait un
moratoire sur cette réforme de la
réorganisation de la police et qu'on
attendent après les Jeux Olympiques à
tout le moins quand bien même on serait
favorable au projet de généralement
la réponse d'abord j'ai compris que vous
étiez aussi la toute réforme donc c'est
bien ou les paraformés vous voulez
mettre des impôts des taxes d'accord
mais pas de toutes les conférences
de proposition de réforme Malaisie
le constat a été fait qu'il y a des
doublons qu'il y a des paires de
substance qu'il y a des compléments qui
peuvent être fait aujourd'hui la police
fonctionne en silo de rapprocher les
deux aujourd'hui en respectant
l'identité de la PJ les moyens de la PJ
et les financements de la PJ à côté on
les respectant aujourd'hui en les
faisant travailler ensemble il s'agit de
faire quoi il s'agit de faire en sorte
que la petite je pense qu'ils gagnent la
délinquance qui gagne aujourd'hui même
la grande qui gagne les petites villes
les Titans à côté puisse mieux
fonctionner parce que les services
fonctionneront mieux entre eux ils font
la moto d'ailleurs tous les syndicats
sont pas opposés aujourd'hui les
expériences qui ont été menées sur le
terrain dans certains départements
montrent que ça peut fonctionner demain
et le ministre a déjà dit qu'il
accepterait qu'il y a une direction
interdépartementale pour le faire mais
je pense qu'au moment c'est justement si
on fait cette réforme c'est pour la
faire avant les Jeux Olympiques et la
Coupe du monde pour que la police soit
plus efficace alors il est pas question
aujourd'hui ma réponse non moratoire non
moratoires aujourd'hui je pense que
cette réforme il faut la faire il faut
la faire par des mesures pas d'abord
pour de l'efficacité supplémentaire pour
qu'ils puissent d'efficacité que chacun
dans son métier soit bien soit bien fixé
rassurer et je crois que le ministre
monsieur Darmanin les a déjà rassuré sur
ce moyen donc je ne suis pas favorable à
ce moratoire mais en réalité la police
judiciaire fonctionne déjà admirablement
ce qu'on appelle police judiciaire la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire un taux des explications
extraordinaires plus de 80% et déjà très
bien organisé sur l'eau du spectre il
manque de moyens il demande pas une
fondue
lisez le rapport de vos collègues
parlementaires il y a le rapport de
philippe Dominati aussi de la commission
des finances qui était très intéressante
qui rentrait au fond du sujet faut qu'on
sorte des soleils on a mis le sénateur
Jérôme Durand était farouchement style
depuis le début donc il allait pas faire
mais madame très bien elle était pas du
tout hostile à réforme et d'ailleurs
moi-même je suis pour réformer la police
nationale encore une fois je vous ai dit
mais pour le coup pour le coup à la
limite pour qui un chef unique de la
police sur police aux frontières voies
publiques renseignement territoriale je
comprends la logique opérationnelle je
l'admets et j'y suis même favorable par
contre je suis favorable à ce qu'on
sanctuarise la police judiciaire et ce
n'est pas vrai qu'avec ce qu'a proposé
le ministre avec des mots et les
sanctuariser non ce n'est pas vrai parce
que nous avons creusé le banc totalement
on a creusé respecter un peu le travail
qui a été fait par les parlementaires
les auditions successives je respecte
surtout le travail causé par le ministre
voilà j'ai bien compris vous avez choisi
votre camp mais ça c'est c'est dommage
vous êtes avant tout parlementaire et
pas membre proche membre du
gouvernementaire qui soutient le
gouvernement pour qu'il réussisse vous
voulez que la France soit à genoux moi
je veux que la France réussisse alors
allons-y continue comme ça je veux pas
que la France ouais le gouvernement
monsieur le gouvernement retire sa
réforme
si vous voulez vous payer le luxe
d'avoir en plus des manifestations de
policiers en plus de celle de tout le
reste du pays qu'on peut réforme des
retraites écoutez débrouillez-vous et
bien voilà c'est le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup juste
une pression parce que c'est important
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé on a
vu des chiffres très récemment vous les
avez vu augmente ah bon bah tant mieux
tant mieux pour les gens c'est bien
aussi que voilà tantôt les gens je sais
que vous alliez vous en féliciter merci
beaucoup Hugo vernalicis reste avec nous
pour la dernière question de Vincent
roux en direct du Figaro live Vincent
c'est à vous alors oui on va essayer de
poser une question intéressante
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
est en train de faire la lumière sur les
raisons de la perte de la souveraineté
énergétique François Patriat et tout le
monde salut le travail qui est qui est
fait
au regard de ce qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui et on a quand même ne vous
en déplaise
frôler le crash énergétique au mois de
gentil au mois de janvier est-ce que
vous regrettez la fermeture de
Fessenheim
je ne regrette pas la fermeture de
Fessenheim parce que quand je connais la
durée de vie je suis pas spécialiste de
cette centrale qui est en Alsace et que
Madame shiningzia connaît bien mieux que
moi je pense que tous les gouvernements
précédents y compris Monsieur Hollande
gouvernement de gauche avait décidé de
fermer Fessenheim parce qu'il y a des
risques dessus et que c'est pour des
raisons politiciennes non non pas du
tout enfin moi je en tout cas je ne les
connais pas donc je vous réponds comme
tel ce que je dis aujourd'hui les
difficultés que nous avons c'est parce
que nous avons tous cédé mais en tout
cas parce que pour ce qui me concerne
vous me reconnaîtrez cela au moment où
le nucléaire n'était pas à la mode où
tout le monde disait qu'il fallait
arrêter le nucléaire en 2050 j'ai créé
dans la région Bourgogne le pôle
nucléaire bourguignon pour garder les
savoir-faire nucléaires avec tous les
entreprises du nucléaire pour les
serviteurs qui vont qui vont nous être
bien utile demain pour pouvoir
construire le nouvel central j'ai fait
le pôle nucléaire le pôle de
compétitivité
sur le nucléaire en 90 alors que tout le
monde s'accordait pour dire le mythe des
50 50 renouvelables et le cinquant
atomique je n'y croyais pas je n'y
croyais pas et je n'y ai jamais cru mais
par contre tous les Français y compris
les citoyens ont vécu avec avec cette
idéologie qu'on pouvait le faire or on
voit bien aujourd'hui compte tenu des
besoins de l'énergie que nous allons
avoir demain qui vont encore se
multiplier avec les voitures électriques
avec tout on a besoin d'énergie
supplémentaire et qu'on échappera pas au
nucléaire ou pas de fermer Fessenheim
moi je connais pas les raisons de
sécurité
je suis pas suffisamment spécialiste du
nucléaire pour savoir si les raisons de
sécurité étaient j'en sais rien moi on
me dit qu'effectivement moi les
responsables du nucléaire me disent
attention c'est une c'est une Centrale
qui était à bout de course qui était qui
pour lequel il y avait des risques
potentiels il y en a d'autres qu'on
devra fermer par le futur celle-là je
pense moi je suis pas à même de vous de
vous donner les éléments de sécurité ou
pas mais je pense que si la décision a
été prise elle a été prise non pas pour
des raisons politiques parce que j'en
vois pas l'intérêt politique aujourd'hui
mais en connaissance de cause risque ça
faisait porter il y avait un intérêt
politique il y avait un intérêt
politique François Patriat il y avait
l'alliance d'abord désocialiste et des
écologistes et ensuite il y avait
l'intérêt politique d'avoir le soutien
de Nicolas Hulot dans au gouvernement et
sa présence au gouvernement donc ça
c'était les ça a été les deux raisons
qui ont été quand même manifeste et que
tout le monde met en lumière pardon il
reste 30 secondes même pas pour répondre
parce que le Président de la République
a montré qu'il savait résister
politiquement aussi bien aux écologistes
il l'a fait il a montré d'ailleurs
Nicolas Hulot et parti donc il était là
pour lui faire plaisir tous les jours il
a su résister il y a quoi l'intérêt
général je pense qu'en l'occurrence cet
avis a été pris sur des bases d'experts
et pas sur des bases politiques comme
vous semblez le dire merci
cent
du débat merci de nous avoir suivi bien
sûr sur LCP Public Sénat on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
édition d'audition publique bonne
semaine à tous d'ici là bonne soirée
[Musique]